[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bon assez à la toto l'or
et louis
je suis journaliste la difficulté de
l'étiquette à cerner aujourd'hui est
manifeste c'est pas toujours agréable il
faut bien le dire fait doit être
journaliste c'est de parler de sport ou
bien de politique d'économie ou
d'environnement sur un clavier devant ou
derrière une caméra ou un micro
ça c'est pour les médias classiques
car pour ce qui est du online et vous le
savez mieux que moi
tout le monde est persuadé d'être plus
ou moins journalistes voilà pourquoi je
vais me concentrer sur un seul aspect du
métier celui de reporter de guerre
en gros c'est un envoyé spécial habitués
et entraîné à pourrir des conflits armés
partout sur la planète tout le temps moi
j'ai choisi de faire ce métier
à 23 ans j'ai commencé par sylvia 60g
l'aise puis chevaux venus en france et
j'ai travaillé pour de grands médias
radio télévision presse écrite
l'express défunt la 5è 6è refi est même
l'équipe
c'est durant ces années là que je suis
devenu reporter de guerre
vous allez peut-être me demander
pourquoi j'ai choisi de faire ça parce
que pour la plupart d'entre nous c'était
tout simplement le plus beau métier
la rolls des métiers du journalisme pour
moi lorsque j'avais votre âge
le corps des correspondants de guerre
c'était l'élite absolue l'ambition
suprême la ligue des champions que je
devais absolument jouer comme ce soir
quand on m'a demandé de venir vous
parler de la peur je vous avoue j'ai
trouvé ça difficile car jamais je ne
pense à la peur avant d'être sur le
terrain
effectivement il faut aller sur place
voir ce qui se passe parce qu on switch
immédiatement sur autre chose
on passe en mode reporter on est dans un
autre film est là tout peut arriver
vraiment tout
vous allez plusieurs fois dans le
caucase c'est à l'est de la russie
les une seule fois en hiver seulement et
croyez moi c'est là je vais me rappeler
toute ma vie imaginez des montagnes
couvertes de neige moins 15 degrés quand
il fait beau
quelque part entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan le nagorno karabagh c'est
un tout petit territoire que les deux
pays se disputent à coups de bombes et
d'obus d'offensive de contre-offensive
toujours sanglante seul journaliste sur
place
j'étais au milieu des réfugiés des
blessés civils et militaires de soldats
de civils armés de médecins et on
attendait tous depuis trois jours dans
des abris à peine chauffés de fortune un
hélicoptère qui devait nous évacuer sur
erevan la capitale arménienne tension
extrême
c'était extrêmement compliqué à faire
techniquement pour des raisons très
simples d'une part la mouette la météo
était particulièrement mauvaise chute de
neige et de louis brouillard en
permanence et d'autre part et c'était là
le grand danger on devait survoler le
territoire de leurs ennemis azéri
c'est-à-dire azerbaïdjanais on attendait
un hélico il y en a deux qui sont venus
nous chercher et aussitôt posé
ils ont été pris d'assaut par la foule
j'étais un peu en arrière on me dit de
monter dans le premier
j'y vais impossible de décoller de
recharger ont fait signe d'aller dans le
deuxième on arriva à décoller enfin on
vole très bas pour les raisons
expliquées tout à l'heure en formation
premier en tête le lien deuxième là
juste derrière et là tout d'un coup
attaque tirs depuis le sol de paix côté
et panique à bord chez nous et s'ils ont
des missiles grad question les soldats
lamont hélico rouge sur la porte
installe deux trépieds d'une énorme
mitrailleuses lourdes et commence à
tirer comme des malades
appuyés par leurs copains qui vidaient
leurs kalachnikov tout en essayant de
préparer un lance roquette qui
finalement n'a jamais marché et la coupe
où on voit le premier hélico qui piquent
du nez et qui s'écrase en flammes
on l'a appris à près d'une quarantaine
de morts à ce moment là nous on continue
monteras fonds sarah fallait toujours de
tous les côtés tout ça hurlait d'un coup
hayastan hayastan c'est là que j'ai
compris qu'on était sauvée parce qu'on
voulait passer en territoire arménien a
après toujours en mode reporter comme je
vous le dis maintenant j'ai appelé paris
pour témoigner
techniquement ça s'appelle un incident
isolé dans une guerre sauf que là j'ai
connu plein de personnes qui étaient
dans le premier league on avait
pratiquement vécu ensemble pendant trois
jours je vous reviens à mon hôtel et je
suis tombé sur une grande table et plein
de français au bout de laquelle trône et
charles aznavour
super je me suis dit c'est un dîner
joyeux mais au bout de dix minutes
plus rien ne passait j'ai brusquement
réalisé que si cet hélico n'avait pas
été trop lourd trop chargé je ne serai
plus là pour rien en fait mort dans la
neige comme les autres du coup j'ai revu
le film je me suis vue avoir peur
surtout au moment où j'ai failli prendre
une balle dans les fesses heureusement
arrêté par le magnéto sur lequel j'étais
assis j'ai froid comme si j'étais encore
dans les nuages à surveiller les tirs
croisés
j'ai revu le brouillard j'ai revu les
trois mètres de neige et j'ai entendu
réellement entendu seulement à l'hôtel
et seulement à ce moment là très
clairement le cri des blessés les
hurlements des femmes et des soldats et
les pleurs constant des enfants
ça a été un moment on se dit et ce qu'on
a peur est ce qu on a pas peur en fait
maintenant je vous dis que j'ai pas eu
le temps d'avoir peur
tout simplement parce que les deux
objectifs très précis à ce moment là
d'abord survivre
même si ça dépendait pas de moi et
ensuite faire mon boulot c'est à dire
envoyer ma correspondance à paris
techniquement ça veut dire écrire un
papier chercher un téléphone croyez moi
c'était loin d'être gagné à l'époque
appelé la rédaction a enregistré ce que
je venais d'écrire là c'est juste un
épisode
j'en ai vécu beaucoup d'autres plus ou
moins mouvementée partout au liban dans
l'ex yougoslavie dans le golfe persique
dans l'ancienne urss
ici à bucarest aujourd'hui en a partout
pareil le venezuela en ukraine il se
passe des choses que vous voyez dans les
journaux ou sur vos écrans
tous les jours y est mais nigeria ainsi
de suite comment est-ce qu'on traverse
tout ça c'est ça la question
et bien si tout simple c'est en se
préparant c'est un entraînement il faut
tout savoir sur la situation sur les
protagonistes sur le contexte local et
international sur qui fait quoi
très exactement de façon à pouvoir
anticiper en permanence savoir toujours
avec un coup d'avancé ce qui peut être
dangereux très dangereux ou trop
dangereux
je parie qu y en a plein parmi vous qui
se demandent en ce moment mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils n'arrêtaient pas faire ça
pour quoi il retourne et se mettre là
devant des années des années après le
caucase dans un autre reportage beaucoup
plus calmes
lors d'une conversation avec une
journaliste américaine attentats je veux
dire la même chose mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça parce que je lui
disais je suis né dans un pays de l'est
que j'ai quittée à l'adolescence ce qui
m'horripile est le plus
outre le manque de liberté c'était
entendre le parti communiste l'être
suprême m'expliquer du matin au soir
ce que je vais faire aimer aimer manger
le parti avait un modèle et une solution
pour tous était parfaitement totalement
insupportable c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu voir la vie par moi même la
réalité pour pouvoir la raconter ensuite
aux autres c'est juste une photo du
moment c'est pour ça que je fais ce
métier clermont a mis américaine aux
grands porteurs avaient vécu une enfance
tout à fait différente à new york
elle cherchait donc notre truc
l'adrénaline
parce que à bagdad à sarajevo
ici à bucarest on a pour tous ailleurs à
damas lorsqu'elle était un reportage
lviv est comme nous tous plusieurs vies
en quelques jours la faim le froid le
sexe la peur l'angoissé l'amour la
tristesse la mort la vie tout simplement
c'était tellement fort quand elle était
en reportage que lorsqu'elle rentrait
chez elle ça lui manquait en ce qui
concerne maintenant avec le recul et
avec l'âge en sachant aussi que ce
métier a totalement changé ça n'a plus
rien à voir
la raison pour notre pour laquelle on
retourne est évidente c'est le mix
parfait entre sa vision est la mienne
autrement dit peu importe la motivation
ce qu'il faut c'est en avoir une et pour
vous pour vous la conclusion est encore
plus simple
toujours à mon avis la peur oublié là et
ne doit pas vous empêcher de réaliser
vos objectifs vous allez préparez vous
allez apprendre les techniques les
procédures la rigueur et la discipline
pour y arriver et une fois l'objectif
atteint
vous pouvez très bien vous retourner
bien regarder en arrière bien regarder
votre peur en face et lui dire cette
fois ci c'est bon ça va ça a marché
on fait pareil la prochaine fois ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]